next month is October that'll be my five
year anniversary of streaming on Twitch
hello sir duck King of the quack
what is this
can I host a viewer tournament
wow it worked okay we're doing a 20
minute viewer tournament featuring this
funny position oh yeah the pieces are
kind of bad here
oh man it's gonna be so hard to get to
the king
we'll figure it out though
good luck to everyone am I gonna play
the chess Prince
am I gonna play anyone
this is not working
did we break leechas is anyone getting a
game
there we go okay
I think it took more work than usual
because it had to
like custom setup
the funny position
[Music]
yeah I wanted to go for his smothered
maze it's not happening though
okay let's expand in the center I'm
gonna give my king some breathing room
I guess I can't Castle
ooh
opponent from Brazil
oh man
okay I just want to expand and the
Bishops are so not useful here
maybe someday they'll be useful
I'm close to getting a pawn diamond
oh I hung upon
This Is Not Great play on my part
okay maybe go for this move
offer the trading nights wow that's a
good move
I'm in big trouble
actually in really big trouble
this position was too funny to
comprehend
maybe I'm okay though there's some
fighting chances
hey it's Gary what's up Gary
yeah if you're just joining we're doing
a funny position viewer tournament
to start the Stream
uh T1
um play this move
very soon this is going to turn into a
bullet game I mean it's already
basically a bullet game
this bishop is lacking squares actually
moves here I played this
and six six
get my Bishop in
hmm
I'm ready to check in Rook D1
it's not so pleasant for black
pawns control most of the squares on the
502 Queen d7's off limits because of
checkmates
I think it's winning for white despite
the fact I'm down
Pawn or down a bishop
yeah check and then King E7 I take and
force the kings of the D file
no mercy here
okay that's a funny start
GG
dial out for berserking I did okay I'm
just working now
uh am I winning I think I'm winning
mate is Unstoppable
oh opening preparation too strong
no draw
okay
I wanted two moves
yeah the king looks so safe until you
realize the king is very smotherable
that game was too short for me to get
the berserking points
I think the game has to be at least like
10 moves for Biz breaking points
okay so I'm gonna move my king
into the small pocket of error
made a little bit of loofed
oh no my Pawn
okay I had to play E5 to stop Knight F4
oh it's not winning though
I thought it was winning
okay let's take
ooh don't hurt me
oh I forgot the berserk
wait opponent's rated 880
I feel like I'm getting outplayed
uh let's play this move making more
aloofed
oh this Pawn is was the spot hanging
earlier
no it wasn't
just after the bishop moved
okay I'm pretty sure this is Unstoppable
now
uh there's there's a few moves there's
Queen moves
but I would have won The Rook or the
other Rook
okay no mercy
I'm leading the way
yeah I wonder how many games this
tournament are gonna feature this uh
like two move checkmates
okay berserking again
wow
a berserking points won't count
I wonder how many of my games will
feature this to move checkmate
I guess it's three moves
see if my opponent allows it
oh it's so satisfying
some people are clearly not watching the
Stream
hey it's Irene
yeah it's still not too late to join
this funny position Arena tournament
12 points so far
oh playing strong player
okay
I'll play my uh same ideas last time
I think it makes sense to just develop
the knights quickly
uh maybe C5
I just realized something
I can smother the queen
the queen is so smotherable
wow
oh the Queen's not smallerable or is it
okay I'm threatening to win the queen
now
but Knight B2
it works on both sides man it took me
only like five games to realize that
yeah the problem is the queen kind of
escapes
so now my plans to go for a meet
opponent wants Knight G7 Maybe
oh there's a lot of things to worry
about here
hmm
my Knight's also hanging
I could play if no E5 doesn't work
to take
is not quite what I wanted
H5
F4 comes
I'll play this
it's already a bit uncomfortable
[Music]
okay at least I have some idea nothing
can really defend the night
it says Bishop's not so useful
I used to play this Rook G3 expected
maybe
ac6
ooh
uh where's the king going
there
let's start with this
so I might just win the bishop
86 King D7
Rook is still hanging
and this this move is still in the air
I'm waiting for the right moment to play
it
wow
are we gonna have some funny mates
come to me
hey it's so funny mate
maybe I should have played Queen F4 kept
attempting the king forward
okay
oh IE Plato is right on my tail
so I have no berserk points
I should have set this uh I could have
could I have set the variant to King of
the Hill
opponent would have won King of the Hill
there
foreign
's completely symmetrical
dough my Pawn
okay it's a Gambit
sagging upon for some activity I think
that was a positional mistake because
Knights have to be better than Bishops
and especially in this position
but I'm not sure by how much
Queen there there there
hmm
we'll start with this
I still want to play this move
I'm threatening made into
meaning 2 involves feeling coloring my
Knights look at this
oh it's too much fun
I think held both nights in my
opponent's territory
okay
I'm trying to
enlarge the gap
between verse and seconds
okay berserking time
well we have a third victim to this mate
not quite
uh
I berserk so I have to move quicker
tonight with rose and Good Times
hey welcome back to Bob also shout out
to Bob
and shout out to Josh
good to see you guys
okay so I guess I'm threatening to trap
the queen with the same idea as that
previous game
or I'm threatening to Checkmate the king
oh I can't stop beating people with the
same checkmates
I've had two games with like Knight G7
mates and then two games with a double
night mates
too much fun
oh man okay
I play those still trying to catch up on
a streak
I've not gotten any berserking points
thus far
hmm
interesting opening
opponent was close to doing the same
thing to me
it could have been Mutual checkmates
okay
thank you black mamba
I was not expecting to play so many
games in 20 minutes
how many games have I played
two four six eight
who's the next person to checkmate
wow opening novelty
so I'm not meeting
I'm gonna play this move and trap the
queen Dole
wow good move
Go Eric also quacking Rose and duck
oh thanks for that hey Amsterdam welcome
back
yeah not too many people know this but
hamsters can also quack
as we just saw
wait how do I do this
I might be in trouble here
what is this position
my G6 Queen H6
or maybe even Queen h8
it's not easy to check me at the king
or is it it might be
oh no box Queen
okay the bishop wants oh I could have
taken a bishop
Jack
foreign
there's a funny on bus on me
oh it's not gonna happen
oh
wait I gotta move quicker
if my knight was still on C5 there is a
cool hump assignment idea
foreign
okay that was a close one that was
probably the closest game
uh
stayed alive didn't flag got berserking
points
please help
wait help with what
also welcome back white noise
happy 43 months and thank you Gus black
first time Prime sub
okay
um
waiting for probably what will be the
last game
um let's try an opening novelty
I like the Rooks coming in
I'm playing chess Prince again
oh chest Prince I'm sure wants revenge
uh don't hurt me
okay this is much higher level from the
previous games
a little bit scared here and I have six
I'm throwing this
I think
yeah this game won't count for the
tournaments
but it'll count for Pride and Glory
yeah this is actually a really strong
threat
because Knight's essentially going to be
trapped and pinned
well that's interesting
I think I still
can do this
oh it's not trapped
or pinned
what is this
move first
so ensuring my queen can either Rook
okay so now the B7 I take and take
I think my King's just chilling
welcome back jumper wood
this position makes me sick
that's why I only set the the viewer
tournament length to 20 minutes
and not two hours
okay White's going for compensation
uh I wanted a pawn diamond
I think I can play this move
no Queen E3 Knight G2 with a fork
the cool tactic now here
Abba Queen
[Music]
okay
I hope people enjoy that
calmest voice in the game
oh thank you General tarby
uh
that was fun I might put that on YouTube
[Music]
uh I have a lot of quick checkmates
thank you to the person who shared this
earlier
Jonas 42
if you're watching in the future on
YouTube I do live stream on Twitch
you can also sub with prime if you have
Amazon Prime
to support the channel
[Music]